yay
we're live with ariana hello hi
hi how's it going
so good
i love those bird chirps in the
background
it's so sweet yes yes yes
i'm so excited for this show ariana has
come on to the scene
of
non-duality
and has taken it by storm with her
direct
pointing and
just uncompromising
addressing of the message
and it's been really exciting
cool
yeah
it's whatever apparently
yeah this is her
awesome
this is what this is this is what she
writes in her
in her video bios
in short the personal self moving
through a journey called time space is a
dream all there is is absolutely nothing
appearing as everything it's completely
unbelievable and unknowable this
communication is not a belief system or
a teaching it is not about logic or
mental understanding this communication
is completely energetic and the words
can resonate
awesome
so
this really kind of plays into the core
teaching of buddha as well which is no
self or anata
and that's
seems to be something that is really
skirted across so frequently by the
individual because they don't want to be
the nothingness that they are they want
to avoid the void
yes
yeah i feel like um
you mentioned teaching there's nothing
to teach really um
and
it's it's actually just very simple
just ordinary life just
all we're talking about is ordinary life
and ordinary life it can be obvious that
this is absolutely nothing
and absolutely not like i i have to say
the word absolutely nothing because
some people think nothing is a something
nothing but it's not a something nothing
it's absolutely nothing um
and it's just this it's a just
everything nothing appearing as
everything so it
and then i have in there it can't it's
not knowable
it's not believable it's actually
shocking when it's seen
um that there's just nothing
uh
but i mean
there's nothing to really see either
because there's nothing to really see
it's just ordinary life yeah
i don't know the core though
was that it's order or though is that
it's ordinary life without a center
oh yeah so
yeah so there can kind of be a a lived
sense of a center
like a kind of a location like the body
is kind of a center location
um
and so that is kind of
on a dream
it's not like your dream at night it's
like a dream is like kind of the best
word i can describe but there's a
can be a lived sense
of a center and i feel that's that's the
common perception
um
i don't know like i like to describe it
as just there's just energy there's just
energy energy appearing as
just the leaves the dirt the air the
hair the shirt the body
everything is energy um sound is energy
light is energy
um water is energy
everything is just energy and if ever
just no separation it's all energy it
just goes on and on and on forever and
it's not big or small
um because it's just boundless energy
oneness it's not it's not big or small
or
relative or absolute because there's
nothing to compare it to it's just
simply just oneness boundless
and um
yeah that's all there really is they're
just energy and it seems like
energy can kind of contract
and that's where it feels like a lived
center kind of like
in water you can have a
ice cube in water and it's like a
contracted version of of water but there
really is no such thing as an ice cube
it's water anyways so there's no real
difference anyways the ice cube is water
the ocean is water and so
it seems like that sense of being a kind
of contracted center
um that sense can kind of not be there
and it's nothing special it's not a
personal experience it's not an
experience of any kind it's actually the
end of experience because it's the end
of feeling separate from things um
yeah
yeah that's a great analogy the ice cube
for the contracted energy everything
being just energy appearing and that
this being energy playing with itself in
that
once we sort of recognize that that's
the case then the center which felt like
the appearance of an ice cube in this
ocean
that
it
merges more and more dissolves more and
more into the ocean or the appearance of
that process is
what apparently happens and that is
probably one of the most exciting things
that can happen is that
a contraction liberates it just feels so
damn good
yeah but in it and it's not even a
process and there's no real method or
because the person
that it's the it's the contraction that
wants the method it's the contraction
it's that sense of separation that wants
to not feel separate so it's kind of
futile or are useless because that
the
that contraction is trying to do more
and try to
search for
something and get somewhere
to get rid of contraction like how can
you know how can a dream it's dreaming
about the end of a dream so the dream
then becomes i'm trying to end a dream
but the dream can't wake up from the
dream and it's just like it's it's kind
of hopeless because that sense of an
individual
that sense of i am the doer
it can't do something to get to some
kind of realization of i'm not the doer
because that that's also the thing like
i talk about just the sense of the doer
is it's an illusory there's no free free
will there's no doer but at the same
time there's a lived reality of i'm the
doer so
when that is seems to be there
there's nothing that can do or not do
because it's not really there already
now but
yeah it's it's weird because that that
that
that artificial sense of person is the
that's the thing that's looking for
something it wants that's the thing that
wants the awakening or the enlightenment
or whatever it dreams about so it's
weird because
when that's not there it's not that you
get an awakening or it's not that you
are some ice cube that melted back into
a hole it's just seen as there was never
an ice cubed female back into the hole
i don't know it just it's not
intellectual that's the thing which is
very frustrating for the person yeah
damn that that part of realization is
quite
fun is that it's the realization also
that there never was an ice cube and
that is one of the
core aspects that sends people into a
into like a big question mark into the
into the mystery because then they
realize that you know how do you turn
around and when people ask from a
contracted place what do i do to
liberate myself then you say that you're
not even contracted in the first place
you're not even an ice cube in the first
place
yeah but i think it can it's a lived
sense it's a it
yeah so you know that it's just what's
appearing because also it's like both
there's nothing to deny or exclude so
you know it's it's already ice it's
already water like there's nothing to
do because like like for example when
people ask me well i still feel like a
separate person i still feel kind of
just separate
it's there's no that's what's appearing
to happen it couldn't be any other way
so
i mean
there's no real like there's no actual
person
but like it doesn't matter whatever's
appearing is what's appearing so
yeah there's nothing there's nothing to
uh
there's actually nothing to even know or
there's actually nothing no realization
um realization is all kind of
in the realm of the person like
when there's a sense of person there's a
sense of
meaning
value purpose
time
space
uh free will
um
there's a sense of
there's something to and get enlightened
there's an awakening there's something
to realize there's actual other people
who've got a realization and i haven't
got that or i have realized something
and there's other people who haven't got
to the level that i'm at
so
there's a sense of comparison there's a
sense of there's others that have or
haven't realized more or less than i
have and so all of that is in just the
realm of the person and all that and so
kind of what i'm speaking about is a
complete departure from all of that it's
complete departure
from
there's ever been something to realize
there's ever been something to get to an
awakening there's you know tr you know
free will you know all of that just it
can't even approach it
logically or mentally because it's just
a complete
exit from
all
all topics and it's just everything so i
don't know but it's absolutely nothing
so it's pointless too
i don't know
do you feel like there's
also a
simultaneity
where there's
both
this
boundless energy that is all already
enlightened
and that even you throw that concept out
it just is boundless energy that just is
and isn't
and then
you
also simultaneously
have
what appears to be
the
contraction that is seeking liberation
so the appearance of an ice cube and
then sort of like varying densities of
ice cube like some ice cubes have
apparently dissolved more and then some
ice cubes are apparently really [ __ ]
huge fat ass ice cubes
um
uh
i
uh
if we're sticking with the ice cube um
metaphor um i think i don't know what i
think
i don't think anything really but um it
seems like it's not like a gradual
process of melting away
um
i think it can be there can be kind of
bang just a glimpse
just a glimpse i would describe a
glimpse as just
ah ordinary life is enough ordinary life
is stunning it's beautiful this is a
miracle it's a mystery that that's all i
can really say about a glimpse just
stunning
and so it seems like when there's a
glimpse it seems like in the glimpse
there's no seeking there's no need for
this to become something else there's no
need to get anywhere there's no need to
change there's no need to
be more some way less this other way
like there's no need for personal growth
personal change blah blah blah and so in
the glimpse it's just wow ordinary life
and it seems like seeking can come
back and it's like wait wait
i want to grasp that i want to know that
i want to find something i want to
understand that but the glimpse
understood or known it's just i mean i
don't know there's not even a real
glimpse anyways but um it seems like
seeking can kind of come back but the
that me that person doesn't come back in
the same way like it may be it could be
softer it could be stronger
i don't know um
yeah that's kind of what happened here
which isn't here or there but like for
me
there was probably like an initial
glimpse in 2018 or something
and then from there
and i didn't know what that was i just
kind of thought whoa
ordinary life this is like a miracle but
and it's not like a mental realization
it's just kind of like
just
unknowable just wonder curiosity but and
then it seems like there were some glimp
some apparent glimpses late like
throughout but i didn't realize this is
i didn't know what this was
um
and then i kind of fell into the rabbit
hole of
there's an actual
thing called awakening that you can
attain or there's an actual thing called
enlightenment or
realization or blah blah blah and so i
actually so then i actually fell for all
this concepts and then i was on a
concept quest actually thinking concept
quest
yeah i was on like i was digesting
concepts and stories and i was basically
eating stories about there's an actual
awakening there's an actual realization
of some kind there's an actual thing
called enlightenment so
and also i was convinced that i had an
ego and so i didn't like this ego and so
i kind of had this inner conflict
where i would almost reject certain
aspects and kind of try to stay as like
some kind of
awareness i don't know what the heck
happened i don't know it's no this is
all a story too but anyways
but but pretty much um yeah i basically
was kind of convinced that awakening had
something to do with knowing more or
attaining more
um but actually all of that is
completely irrelevant because
in the apparent glimpse it's just ah
it's just this
just the view just ordinary life there's
nothing to know or understand or realize
um
[Music]
and yeah it seemed like there were more
and more
apparent glimpses and um
it kind of got to a point where it's
like almost like a light turning on and
off and
kind of like before that light burned
out
it was just almost flickering like you
know when when your light bulb is gonna
burn out starts to flicker like it just
loses steam and so uh that was that but
when it burns out it's obvious that
there never was a separate light in a
separate light bulb really you could say
there's only light there's only energy
there's this this so there never was a
separate light bulb anyways so and
that's another metaphor too which is
just like cut up too which goes in the
garbage too because no concept can ever
know the view no concept can ever
understand ordinary life
but unfortunately or fortunately not
unfortunately unfortunately but the
person is kind of this addiction to
concepts and addiction to knowledge
addiction to knowing more retaining more
but really there's no answer there's no
way to know this there's no way to grasp
and understand this because it's all
when i say this it's already the sound
of the description it's already
immediately just seeing and listening
and this
so i can't know it but
so then what would you say
is
what would you say you are
now do you say you are mystery that you
are boundless energy
i wouldn't say i am anything cause
because any anything i would say would
be a concept or a story and all the
concepts lost their value and their
meaning
every single it's all equal every single
concept is blah blah blah that's kind of
the it's just a
profound brain shift because
it's almost like i was hypnotized or
drunk on meanings and values and i
actually thought um
um
you know energy is has a different value
than the word ice cream
or um
you know what i mean
so even the word mystery or boundless
energy is equivalent to ice cream
yeah the word mystery is equivalent to
garbage so you know or a swear word it
doesn't matter you know the mo god is
equivalent to
a swear yeah garbage you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah anything so so yeah
cool okay so there's so now there's more
there's more of an e there so the person
makes the distinctions and value and
that then awakening then is this
evenness
of it all
well there's no real awakening but yeah
the person is projecting
kind of like a movie projector like
projecting onto this
it projects meaning and value onto
everything so and each each one of these
apparent individuals is projecting their
own belief system
so
you know
so you know some spiritual
character is gonna project their own
meanings and beliefs about everything it
sees and it might see value in
um
a retreat it sees meaning and value and
some kind of spiritual retreat but maybe
some kind of engineer
um
is that's projecting different meanings
and values onto everything onto the view
um
and it might see zero value in something
like a spiritual retreat for example
but
what i'm speaking about is the end of
all projecting it's the end of
projecting any meaning or value
it's the end of projecting any beliefs
or meanings
it because all concepts can really be
start to sound like blah blah blah
stories um yep
yeah
so to answer your question though what
do i think i am
there's there's no i am to be
anything i there's there's no need to be
a concept or to not be a concept like
there's just no individual which is
yeah can't it can't be a it can't be
really
understood when yeah i don't know
i don't know there's no i am i am is
just another concept just like mystery
or garbage
so the apparent
ice cube
the appearance the parent center
the parent contracted energy projects
out all of this meaning
value distinction purpose
all of the
belief system projected outward and then
as that apparent ice cube dissolves the
contracted energy dissolves liberates
itself that belief system and value and
distinction
and meaning
it collapses into an evenness that it
always was
yeah i like evenness evenness yeah
there's no
hierarchy or values or um
like there's still kind of preferences
kind of that's kind of just how it is
like you like vanilla or chocolate ice
cream you like you're you wait you're a
morning person early bird or you're a
night owl like you know there's
preferences but as far as um
[Music]
just everything there's no separation so
there's no
there's no separate values or separate
meanings or there's absolutely no
meaning at all
and there's no separate events divided
by time there's no separate objects
divided by space
um
but yeah back to the ice cube melting
it's not like this is a gradual process
over time because there's no time really
um
and also
um
yeah i mean it seems like intellectually
the beliefs can kind of get untangled
and intellectually this can kind of a
lot of that neurosis and concepts can
kind of
start to
um get untangled but ultimately
kind of the awakening
is
bang it's sudden it's just this
so
but i can't know that that's just
describing what happened here what
happened to me or not to me but here
whatever
it didn't happen to a me because it's
the end of the me but um
it was basically like kind of certain
beliefs and meanings kind of starts to
unclutter it's not as messy it kind of
starts to untangle
but that really has nothing to do that
can or can't happen but it doesn't have
anything to do with when it's just bang
ordinary life this
just it's shocking it's just shocking
ordinary life so
um
yeah i don't know i don't know but yeah
and then what you're saying about kind
of that
projecting and the subject obj like i
was going to add their like subject
object reality when you feel like a
subject
when you you see separate objects
you see separate objects
in space but really there's no space so
so for example i'm seeing a tree
and a house and a chair and a body
and and the person sees these as
separate objects it's seen through its
concepts it's seen through its meanings
and it's you know
but really there's no distance between
this body and
the wall and this body there's no
distance between me and you right now
there's no space it's all energy
um
so it's like
it's totally like kind of uh
the mind just kind of fights this i
guess that seems to can seem that way
but
i don't know there's no space really
there's no distance between you and the
moon because there's no separate you and
there's no separate moon it's all energy
um
you know and there's no distance between
there's no you know there's no earth and
sun there's no distance between the
earth and the sun it's all boundless
energy
and then it seems like an earth is
appearing a sun is appearing but really
there's all just boundless energy
there's no boundary there's no
separation it's all energy
it just it can never be known the
thought kind of hits the limit
i don't know
yeah yeah
[Music]
this is the
the apparent
yeah thought hitting the limit the
apparent
moth
into flame
of mystery
and
free fall
yeah free fall yeah yeah so then this
evenness is really interesting because
it
it is really freeing because then
the when there's evenness there's not a
fixation
uh on a separate
subject or a separate object in
in time
space
and then that's really
liberating because there's no points of
fixation perpetually that happened yeah
yeah there's no really fixation on a
thing because it's obvious there's no
such thing as a thing
there's no thing
like um
totally the person is just addicted to
things and concepts concepts are just
mental things things things things
there's separate things there's this
thing in that thing and yeah apparently
yeah of course apparently there's a
thing called
um
i don't know
a vacation and a thing called um
i don't know what's awesome like
you know winning the lottery and a thing
called like there's all these things or
a thing called um
you're
you know this person that you hate or
this person that you
you like and there's these things and
the person chasing whatever thing it
wants to chase and avoiding whatever
thing he wants to it's just a chasing
avoiding energy it's this body sense of
chasing one thing avoiding another thing
and it doesn't matter what it is um
chasing fame avoiding um
whatever the opposite is chasing chasing
pleasure really it's chasing pleasure
and comfort and good stuff it's avoiding
discomfort bad stuff
whatever so that's the whole energy of
the person it's just it's just chasing
pleasure
um fixated on whatever it thinks it's
going to bring it pleasure happiness
meaning purpose enlightenment awakening
all of these words are interchangeable
it's a pleasure whatever whatever the
person thinks is the ultimate
thing to get it's basically chasing
whatever idea it has about the ultimate
thing it wants
yeah so then the person
when there's an apparent person
that then that center will then
pursue what is pleasure and avoid what
is pain and then that becomes its
perpetual fixation until it liberates
itself of that center of the meat
yeah yeah yeah
kind of kind kind of and that's a story
too but yeah like
but but kind of yeah it's chasing this
idea so you know it could be chasing
money chasing the the
the right partner chasing the marriage
the kids the house
um
the awakening awakening is just another
thing to chase pretty much
it doesn't matter what it's chasing but
it can't really do anything else that's
kind of had the function of it it's just
chasing what it wants to chase it's it's
seeking it's search it can't because
then even if it's says oh crap i'm
always searching i'm always chasing what
have i been doing then it basically is
gonna search to not search and so then
it will get into spirituality okay
meditation is gonna help me relax and be
at peace and i won't search
so it's basically searching through
trying to not search and so all it can
really do is search search search search
search even if it's
searching to ease the searching
if that makes any sense
yeah and that's all it can do it's kind
of helpless in that sense because it's
just a body sense of searching
the contracted energy is the body sense
of searching
but that's a story too anyways so
there's no real
method or definition but the person will
maybe listen to this video and it's
really looking for something it thinks
that you know she's gonna say something
important she's gonna give out the
answer or she's gonna say something that
finally gets me to the realization i
want to get to
i saw i saw ariana in one of her videos
she was fielding some questions
and
she her response to
uh someone asking her the question was
something like uh
uh no there you're already you're
already it i can tell you're waiting for
me to give you something with a with a
notepad so that you can write down the
strategy that you have to do
yeah that's what it does the me is the
note taker the me is the the the it's
it's really like you're really sitting
on the edge of its seat all the time it
thinks that it's always around the next
corner my realization it's one more
video away one more book one more
retreat one more it's the addiction to
one more it's the addiction to what's
next it's the addiction to the next
concept but really what it's doing is
it's just rearranging its concepts it's
just concept play all your concepts it's
just clay and so you just rearranging
your clay you're rearranging your legos
your little lego concepts in your head
it's just it's just rearranging its
concepts but all the concepts can all be
seen as equal just legos just mental
play mental clay it just it just can't
like it yeah so that's that's the whole
energy of it the third the body sense of
searching is is it really feels like
there's an answer that's just it's it's
it's just almost there
it's a sense of almost there i'm almost
at the awakening i'm almost at the at
the realization you know i've i've come
a long way i've i've awakened a lot i've
realized a lot but you know there's just
one more thing and it's finally done it
it's a sense of that
the
the case will finally be closed case
closed i get it
um or
because also it feels like a project you
feel like you are a project your story
your journey is like a project and so
you think there's a final the project
will finally be done but it's not that
the project gets to a done there's no
conclusion
it's kind of
the project falls apart there never was
something to build up
but it's this building up becoming
getting somewhere project
rearranging your concepts
always at the edge of your seat waiting
for someone to tell you what to do or
you know to tell you how to get
somewhere
it's just obvious there's nothing to get
nothing to know but that that plays out
till it plays out um i mean sorry that
did not play that that plays out until
it doesn't
searching plays out until it doesn't
there's no real choice in it
yeah
i love how
uh adi ashanti also calls this uh
a demolition project because you when
you have that sense of me
it's about becoming it's about acquiring
concepts like you said the legos
shifting the them in this mental lattice
work of oh i will get this and then i'll
be happy and whatnot
and then this deconstruction or
demolition project is sort of like an
apparent
emptying of the center of the self
and then
there's a
there's a shift to just pure beingness
um and a shift to that boundless energy
and which you were the entire time but
you got into this of contraction into
this the first thing that i would say on
it if you are to you know mention
something to people that do ask um it
does feel like the number one thing that
you
and jim newman and uh tony parsons and
the nothing
community nothing media community it
does feel like the number one thing
that's sort of being
um said is that
there is no separate you or me and so
when you sort of like you know empty out
that center that's like the number one
thing and this is what buddha taught
with dependent origination as well is
that you get rid of the sense of i
me mine or self no self
that was never there and that by doing
so then this is how this is like the
number one thing that seems to be
pointing at is that what you would also
suggest
i mean i would say yeah the the
the main thing is there's no separation
so there's no separate you um
but then there comes in this layer of
some majority of apparent speakers say
okay so there's no you so here's how you
can clean out your concepts and get to
that so here's how you can realize
there's no you
and so it keeps it going on a
merry-go-round
going okay you can realize there's no
you here's how you can do that here's
spring cleaning you know let's clean out
those you know not needed beliefs like
it's just it's just trying to
it's going it's it's it's these these
speakers that um they perpetuate the
thing that they claim they can end
kind of but really it's not that it ever
started and so there is no method that
works because nothing works because it's
already not there so it can be obvious
being obvious that it never was
um
but
yeah
yeah i don't know
but what you were saying about
you know
that you had
empty what did you say like opening up
in the concepts or something what did
you say oh the emptying of the self it
sort of it looks a little bit like a
shift from like a bubble
right here
to like a doughnut where there's no
center
oh no then that's another concept yeah
cause it's just immediately it's just
this so yeah so um
yeah
but but you know when i felt like
someone um
i like uh it was actually pretty bad
like i was
um highlighting
stuff taking notes all these journals
all these notes um
uh
trying to understand really really
trying trying trying uh trying to make
sense of
whatever i was trying to know
and so it's not like
and so it's not that i had to undo all
of that or put in some kind of effort to
backtrack and do something else it's
that bang
spontaneously
it was obvious that all my notes were
just squiggly lines the letters the
words meant nothing
all the concepts are just little
squiggles on a paper it doesn't mean
anything there's no value in any word
it's all just blah blah blah squiggles
on a paper or or sound so
yes yeah but as long as there's a sense
of me it doesn't
see
the beautiful visual of just the
squiggles and words it doesn't see the
beautiful richness of sound because it
hears meaning and here's what it
interprets it hears its concepts
it you know so it's in a daydream of
stories just addicted to stories i don't
know and that's a story too so there's
no real explanation or no way to know
anything
but yeah i don't know
yeah this resonates a lot that it's
there isn't when we look out we're the
ones that are projecting out
what is the differentiation between a
tree and garbage and concrete
and water and all those things we just
ascribed all of these names to form
and then the appearance of it
and then that has perpetuated over
thousands of years is this
is this addiction to symbolization and
describing
and then sort of the cessation of the
symbolization and describing
brings nation that none of it actually
has any symbolization or description or
name
and that we're just projecting that on
to it
and then
there's a huge liberation with that
but yet there's also like
then when
when somebody asks you know
like ariana do you want like what do you
want like some
um
tea or coffee or whatnot
that you still can access there you go
yeah you still can access said
um
the diff you can still access the
apparent differentiation between the two
so there is use to it so like when a
seeker comes and asks a question about
you know how to uh dissolve this
contracted energy um there is use in
accessing some sort of
concept that
the
um the sharer of the message can then
just share that concept as directly as
possible to help
this other
piece of life
undergo the dissolving of said
contracted energy and feel liberated
yeah apparently i don't know i just i
apparently just speak and apparently
there are questions and apparently
there's a response
um
and i i don't really feel like i'm
helping anyone because i don't feel like
there's anyone over there because
there's no one here and no one anywhere
there's just energy just obviously
energy and um
yeah but then that's a story too and
then when there's a
person there's an interpretation maybe
that's the entire different
interpretation that you know maybe
someone says oh this wonderful ariana
she's helping everyone get somewhere
that's not true there's no true or false
anyways but and then maybe it's oh this
is a real this girl doesn't know
anything who does she think she is you
know and both are equal they're both
just beautiful life expressing um
and i don't really feel like i'm helping
or hurting anyone because it's not that
i don't feel like i'm helping or hurting
it's that there's absolutely no one to
help her to hurt
you know there's absolutely just nothing
it's just it
can't can and that sounds very um
yeah that's kind of threatened something
it's the sense of person which
i don't know it's just it's kind of
yeah it kind of can be very confronting
i don't know
i don't know what i'm saying i'm going
to do some backgrounds and i'm like oh
god it's quite confronting it is quite
confronting
because
if you look back at us
um which again is a story but if you
look back at us
you know three years ago that when we're
sort of getting
um the pointing of that there is no i me
my self
center um
that
it's confusing and it's it's it's it it
can appear to be confusing to said
separate seeking energy and so and so
now you're
in the apparent seat doing that to
yourself apparently three years ago and
so that's the sort of way to like view
the
scenario so like you're kind of in a
sense you're serving the the unbounded
energy is serving itself in awakening
to itself apparently but from this
apparent perspective that's a story
so i i can't really agree or disagree
because that's another story too
um but i guess
i don't know i don't know there's not
really but i yeah i can say that um
like
in the apparent past when i heard this
there was a little me that felt very
threatened and i felt this was
confronting
because there was a little me like i'm
just a little me here like how could
this be like boundless and nothing
appearing as everything like a very uh
threatening um the thought kind of hit
the limit
thought got to its max like it can't
grasp it it just can't grasp it um
and so
i don't there's no process nothing
really happened
and it's just kind of like
all i can all i can say is i felt like a
person
i heard this message it was very
threatening and confronting um i was
very provoked that the parent mind was
very extremely provoked because all the
concepts started shaking it's like jenga
you know all those concepts
and bang there's no now there's just
this there's just ordinary life and that
that illusory sense of a little me in a
big world that like that sense of me as
a center if there's no it's not there to
be provoked or to not be
confronted anymore it's not there but
and i don't know and it's almost like it
never was it's almost like that was a
complete dream it never was that that
body sense and also i would describe it
as self-consciousness kind of that sense
of a center is self-consciousness
and it's also this sense of free will
where you have a choice to to kind of do
all these things like awareness and
pulling back and observing and you and
then also i also and now i'm just going
on tangents but like also
when i felt like me i had all these
little skills where i could pull back
from thoughts and i could watch the mind
and do all these fancy things but all of
it is just aspects of the person it's
all all these spiritual techniques and
skills and this and that it's all
aspects of the person but what i'm
speaking about is a complete departure
from that perception which can't be
understood by that perception like the
person can't understand its own absence
it can never know its own absence
because its own absence is not about
knowledge
and it's not about unknowing either
there's no knowing and there's no
unknowing because people then the person
thinks oh i don't okay knowing is old
school i'm gonna get to unknowing but
you know that's another journey
i'm going to get there
becoming yeah so it's not something to
get there's no journey there's no
process it can just be being obvious
that ordinary life is i love that
let's play with that i i actually i
really like the way you describe that so
it it seems as though the most
um
direct way to
describe this
to an extent is what you've been
referring to as
bang obvious
i like that
yeah yeah i like that i i feel like that
is um
that if there was a pointing that was
like most direct it would just be the
bang obvious like
like
and that doesn't even happen but but
just that at least like can we can we
like not like some in in you know
one year or whatever that there will be
an emptying or whatever but just the
bank
but just the bang obviousness of
that i as a separate person don't exist
there is only boundless energy
and yeah
yeah i love the bang obviousness to it
and
i feel like
um
if we can sort of
put that
more into the cultural of of the well of
non-duality especially like when as you
keep
sharing being obvious being obvious i
really like that a lot rather than
like
rather than saying there is
um
you know no you or there's nothing to do
or that those those things um
they're they're not as direct to a
certain extent as when you say it can be
bang obvious
because then then somebody is like uh
ah it
that shift that we were talking about
the apparent shift that we were talking
about being obvious yeah yeah and also
because also all of that stuff like
there's nothing to do or there's no you
to do or to not do or there's this or
there's no free will because even all
this non-duality talk can also be seen
as
blah blah concepts
like even you know what i'm saying like
you know all of this free will this that
nothing to do all of this can also be
blah blah blah squiggles on a paper
sound it's just concepts again
so even non-dual there's no such thing
as non-duality anyways so you know i'm
not even a non-duality speaker i'm not
there's nothing non-duality and what the
heck is non-duality there's no there's
no such thing as duality or non-duality
so um
but as far as being obvious like i feel
like
that
yeah like it just suddenly
just this it can be obvious that
everything you're looking right now
is nothing
every everything everything you're
seeing right now is absolutely nothing
just the view it's just nothing there's
nothing behind the view there's nothing
in front of the view there's nothing
even in the view
it's completely just nothing
and it's not even nothing it's not
nothing and it's not not nothing it's
just just
it's just this
um which is threatening to the sense of
a someone because the someone is at
something that's these other somethings
yeah
and that's fine too because that's just
unconditional life appearing as oh a
shaky little me
you know yeah
exactly
that's perfection also it is yes yes
cool
there's a
there's an excitement when
you
perpetually remind us that
even non-duality duality even nothing
and everything is just concepts
yeah and and that's really cool um
because it just takes us back into just
this again a concept but just unbounded
beingness
or
it's just so rich right here bang
obvious like whoa
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's nothing to even say because it's
just
it's just ordinary life
just ordinary justice
just this
and so it's very just it's very natural
too because it's just like newborn baby
so
the newborn baby
didn't do anything to get to just
already just
just shocking it's just ordinary life
you know
so the newborn baby didn't do anything
it didn't search for anything it didn't
get anywhere it did not get anywhere it
just actually there's no such thing as a
separate newborn baby anyways it's just
energy appearing as that but
um
yeah
but apparently the adult
feels like it has to do something or get
somewhere or know something or grasp
concepts to get to some kind of
uh outcome or result
but the newborn baby doesn't have to do
any of that garbage right so
it's kind of a joke the adults just
going on a merry-go-round of concepts
and searching and
yeah
yeah that's great and then then that
also deeply
plays into what
we've been
sharing as
a natural state versus an altered state
again just concepts and a dualism but
that this altered state is what is in
the mainstream culture of separation and
ego and contracted person energy and
that the natural state is a state like
you described where it's energy
appearing as a newborn baby that is
innocent without any concepts whereas
these adults in mainstream are just on a
conceptual merry-go-round seeking
pleasure avoiding pain
and it's it's an absolute nightmare of
insanity
yeah
it's an apparent nightmare but but um i
wouldn't use i wouldn't say that it's
two different states i would say that
you know the newborn baby
that's not
a state it's it's it's inclusive of all
states you know there's full-on crying
there's full-on laughter there's full-on
just pure wonder
you know
and there's it's not a specific state
it's just full-on life um full-on
immediately ordinary life all the time
the ordinary is the extraordinary it's
not a state
but what happens is it seems like when
after the newborn baby gets a bit older
it starts to feel like a someone it
starts to feel like an identity so when
that when that sense of identity is
there it's i gotta make a good identity
i gotta i may have a good life i have to
get my life right i have to get
somewhere i have to become something i
have to get this right i have to be
someone blah blah blah blah blah blah
and so there's a never-ending list
and so
so and then it's here's this
communication it's like oh craps you
know let me throw out all my other goals
now my goal is to get to the state of
the newborn baby or i want to get back
to my natural beingness well then it's
just chasing that it's just chasing that
again it's chasing i want to get to
some kind of peaceful
thing so it what i'm speaking about is
in a specific state or a specific thing
which is then again frustrating too
because the person really wants it
really wants to grasp something but you
know i'm not talking about something
you'll ever be able to grasp because
it's already everything it's not
graspable it's actually the end of
grasping yeah the end of grasping
yes
yes being fixation
separation
value meaning
concepts
yeah that's great
it's good stuff
another way of
sharing what you've said
as
the view of nothing being everything
is also energy dancing vibration is that
resonant for you
yeah um yeah you could say energy
dancing it's just a light show but um
also it's not for anyone there's no
viewer or observer or perceiver that's
seeing that and um and
and vibration i find that then there's
separate
types of vibration and higher and lower
and there's a me over here that can feel
the vibration of that over there and so
there's a sense of me as this object and
then there's something else with a
vibrate separate vibrations but really
they're just one
boundless vibration really but i mean
that's if you want to use that word but
um
yeah
so
so vibration
being like the underlying
substrate or substratum and then the
appearance
of
a
vibration in differentiation
is sort of what we're talking about or
what is uh whereas the where the
appearance is why people attend
your
uh non-duality meetings because they're
trying to they feel contracted they're
trying to
acquire
something to feel liberated and so there
is an apparent differentiation in
vibration where you feel
liberated and they feel contracted and
that but what underlies everything is
the same energy
yeah yeah yeah i get what you're saying
um
like uh i mean it's really just there's
there's just there's just life and it
seems like then there's this extra
extra feature
of
a me
kind of like um kind of like uh
um
i don't know how what else to compare to
but like
um
i mean
i don't know where to would say but like
yeah like
it can be a kind of it's a different
tone
when
um when there's a person speaking and
when there's
speaking with no sense of person because
when there's a person if there's
compromises um there's sympathy there's
personal sympathy oh you feel this way
let me help you here's a technique
here's a method blah blah blah blah blah
and so it's person to person and there's
a personal relationship there's a
student-teacher relationship that feeds
into each other
yeah and then as far as just it can be
just a whole different tone a very kind
of confronting uncompromising unexpected
tone
when there's no one speaking there's
immediately speaking there's no one in
here thinking about what's going to be
said there's no one in here
there's absolutely no one in here to to
contemplate different concepts because
there's no more uh addiction to concepts
it's just speaking like music um so i
guess what you're saying like it's a
different tone
when it's when it's clear and
uncompromising uh compared to when it's
a person that's teaching something to
someone who says they are a seeker or a
student because from this perspective
there's no such thing as a seeker
there's no such thing as
i can't see a seeker or a person there's
just unconditional energy unconditional
life
yeah
i love your music theory
um analogy because we were just talking
to andres gomez emilson who's a
co-founder of qualia research institute
on the show as well and
it's a really interesting analogy to use
music theory which is what they're also
using as well which is that the
underlying is that same energy and then
there's the appearance of the music
as a self or as a no-self and when it
appears as a no-self it's way more
fearless and uncompromising and
spontaneous and it it it when it and
when it speaks into the field it speaks
um
from a place of no self not from a place
of self of needing to extract things it
speaks from a place of just play
childlike innocence but yet there's some
sort of sage-like wisdom that is also
aiming to serve what appears like
contracted energy to liberate itself
because it knows it as itself
yeah i don't know i mean that's what the
interpretation could be yeah that could
be the way it could be interpreted but
um from this perspective there's no
value or meaning in anything i'm saying
and it's not special or anything
um but
yeah yeah i don't so that could be the
interpretation but there's no agenda
yeah is it cutting out no no but i i
have an intro i have an interesting
question for you though yeah
so
you're a bit blurry for me but it should
be fine okay okay cool it's crisp on my
end okay so so do you ever feel like
the
like
simultaneously
the
it's it's completely
um
nonsensical to try and put the wind into
ideas
like this is the wind and we're trying
to put it into ideas and concepts and
try and talk about it
and and yet at the same time
there is in a sense
an appearance of a collective awakening
and that it can be helpful
for us to figure out
what are some of the best ways to
talk about this yeah which then serves
the collective awakening
as far as collective awakening so
actually that's an interesting question
because when i felt like a person i
actually felt like i was on an awakening
journey
and i felt awakening was special and i
felt like
we all can wake up there's gonna be a
global awakening everyone's gonna start
popping and everyone's gonna wake up and
um
and it will be a global awakening it's
gonna there's gonna be world peace and
all these other things will unfold
naturally we'll stop hating each other
the wars the conflicts it's all gonna be
amazing so i thought awakening was just
this heaven this utopia just everyone's
gonna wake up um
and and also i thought you know you i
had all these meanings like one of the
meanings i had was um
i thought humans are special because we
have we're the only species that can go
around and help all the other species
like we can save the polar bears we can
help the bees we can feed the bird like
we're the only i thought humans were
special so i thought everyone's gonna
wake up and we're all gonna help the
other species we're gonna save climate
change we're gonna you know so as a
person i thought awakening was this
grand thing and collective awakening
especially global awakening all this
stuff but now i'm sober from all those
stories like all that is just stories
and fairy tales um because even that
like this is already perfection like
perfection plays out as you know
conflict and world wars and all that
stuff you know
the me
thinks that um
it's the me is trying to get to this
like fantasy
state or this fantasy collective thing
of like a peaceful amazing great world
where everyone is happy or something um
whatever it is the me has an idea of
something better or something else and
it's not just for its own self it has an
idea for the world the collective maybe
awakening is the good thing that's going
to be great for everybody right so
whatever it is or um everyone you know
traveling to space or whatever the idea
it doesn't matter the point is that the
me has an idea that there's a different
situation that's eventually we're going
to get to this future it's going to be
better or something
but like
if the me actually got its fantasy
hypothetically if you actually got this
ideal
world if you actually got to this ideal
situation it would be hell you think
it's going to be heaven but it would be
hell because if you actually got to all
the time happiness happiness would be
flat line there would be no such thing
as happiness because it would be flat
line happiness it would just be flat
line if you got to this ideal of always
blissful heaven magical sparkles it's
flat line so what i'm suggesting is
ordinary life exactly as it is anger
frustration sadness pain grief joy
laughter um a pandemic
everything exactly as it is full on life
and just contrast everything full-on
and so it's a hopeless thing because the
me is trying to get this ideal goal or
this ideal dream
it is a dream me is the dream but it's
trying to get to this thing like we're
gonna get eventually to this amazing
awakening we need to help people there
are actual people we all can help each
other to get to an awakening blah blah
blah and there's gonna be a better world
and it's gonna affect all our society
and our systems and our education system
and our this and our that and it just
has a huge belief system and and if we
just shift if we just shift it from
it being the me that is conceptualizing
it rather than it
and we shift it to the
the boundless energy itself
dancing
to awaken
to itself
yeah
yeah yeah yeah sure
yeah so
that well well that shift is it seems to
be really important because
when it's a me
that is
creating some sort of awakening then
that's a completely different story than
when it's
a
the boundless energy
itself recognizing that this is the game
that it's playing with itself and that
where
the plane
or the airplane
where
there's both what you describe
as what is
just as it is
already perfection including everything
that you described in that list
and yet there's also the appearance
of
the boundless energy
awakening from its contractions
yeah
but then that's like
but then that that is a story so the
person feels like the person feels oh so
i'm contracted and and i i'm gonna have
some explosive experience where i awaken
to myself my i'm i'm boundless energy
but one day i'm gonna get some explosive
experience where i'm gonna wake up to
myself and i'm gonna
i'm gonna
um i'm gonna recognize myself as
everything and i'm the boundless like
it's not like that it's just suddenly
bang looking at the walls it's suddenly
bang using the toilet it's bang
cooking some pasta it's just gonna be
paying ordinary life so it's not a
magical body
thing where you have a you know what i'm
saying so it thinks i'm the boundless
and i will recognize this like it cannot
be because
it would take it would take a knower to
know that like so that's also the thing
like as a person i felt
i'm a separate person and one day i'm
gonna know when i'm not separate
or i felt i'm a separate person and one
day i'm gonna have some grand big
explosive awakening
but
that whole thing was a daydream that
there's actually gonna be something that
happens to me
because now
i don't i there's no one here to know if
i'm separate or if i'm not separate
there's no one here to know if there's
boundless energy or if there's not
boundless energy there's no one here to
know if there's a mystery or if there's
not a mystery there's simply just this
it's not knowable
but
all that
the the daydream is the daydream of
getting an awakening or an explosive
experience or some realization so that
fantasy that daydream of me thinking
that i'm gonna actually have an
experience in the future that whole
mental fantasy
was all just a mental fantasy it was all
just thoughts and concepts and ideas and
a daydream there's never been anything
other than ordinary life or just the
dirt the wind just this nothing special
about the wind it's it's it's just as it
is
and so
it's not something the person kind of
rejects this or tries to accept this it
doesn't really matter it's not about
rejecting or accepting because there's
no one to do that anyways but um
yeah
yeah so it's kind of weird it's not what
it's not
what the person expects it
it's going to be the person expects it
to be
yeah a great
amazing
thing
but it's just
this ordinary
life
which is amazing it's the original life
like oh
so i think people
see my
so
excited just it's
this this
but but i'm not
excited because i'm seeing something
and
experience it
it's simply just
ordinary life is enough i don't feel
like i have to become anything i
don't
feel like i have to get anywhere i don't
feel like i need to change myself or do
it like i don't
feel like
i'm the doer doing it
but i also don't feel like i'm not the
doer so it's not like door to not feel
separate there's no one to feel like a
self or to not this person is like but
there's no eye to be either of those
really there's no separation
i don't know it's just
i don't know
beautiful
so we'll wrap here in a little bit this
has been
quite exciting for our first
conversation a nice little dive in
together it's been awesome
yeah it's been fun playful
it's been nice
i loved it it has it i love it
i love to talk i love to express i love
just life
so i don't know
and the outside thing worked out i guess
so this is fine
yeah
but anyways
i do feel like that's one of the
core
exciting
aspects to
the content that you share
is that
you have that fascination
with ordinary life which is so beautiful
and
then you also love to share
about the bang obviousness
and
that's so great
yeah yeah and i'm it's not even mine and
i don't have anything but um
but
like i just love it and just this and
i don't know
so
yeah
yeah and i always was like so like even
like even before like i was i always
loved to share and express even though
before i was trying to convince people
of concepts
that i believed in
before i was trying to share and
convince people and share my advice
share my concepts and share my thoughts
and my beliefs and blah blah blah so i i
was always kind of like this but now
it's kind of speaking without
a backpack of beliefs it's kind of
speaking without kind of
uh holding this collection of concepts
but that's a story too so
there was never any concepts anyways to
grasp anyways well there are apparent
concepts but only apparently
everything's only apparently
just
apparent everything's only apparently
real pretty much the the person thinks
it's absolutely real but
i also really love these
very friendly
you just used
the
backpack of beliefs that's a great one
and then there's another one you said
earlier the con the concept quest
i love that one
and i remember when we were messaging
when we were when we were messaging you
also said concept tornado
so concept quest concept tornado
uh backpack of beliefs those are so good
yes
the the person is a concept tornado and
so these apparent people interact and
they're just trading concepts with each
other
here i'm a psychologist let me trade
some concepts with you you're a
scientist trade some concept let's
exchange knowledge let's you know pass
along information it's just a bunch of
walking concept tornadoes so
nothing wrong with it that's boundless
perfection appearing as blah blah blah
talking heads you know
i love
no offense to anyone but you know
those are great though those are those
are insightful because if if you're
if you're
if you're just
present
with the concept tornado or with the
backpack of beliefs or the concept quest
if you're
present with those you'll notice more
and more frequently when you feel like a
concept tornado and maybe that you can
let go of that and then it feels more
liberating when you let go of the the
concept tornado but yeah it is
the boundless energy appearing as a
concept tornado which is still
perfection
yeah but um but that whole thing about
oh okay let me just observe that or be
aware of it or let it go it's really
difficult like it's really like i never
was successful with letting anything go
i was never good at any of that stuff
like
that's the person doing a skill
if the person feels separate from their
beliefs they feel like there's me
and then there's the beliefs i'm i'm me
or i'm the observer i'm the aware
presence i'm the presence or the being
and then there's my concepts and
thoughts and beliefs so that whole sense
of i'm separate from my thoughts and i
have my beliefs like
it's kind of all the person it's all one
package so it's not that there's a you
that has the beliefs
it's all one package the you is the
beliefs you are the belief system the
the the person is the backpack the
person is the belief
so like then there's no one left so then
there's absolutely nothing left nothing
to grasp no one no one to have or not
have
it's just everything blows up
everything just blows up it just
just
but when there is a sense of person
there's a sense of
maybe i can let go maybe i can surrender
maybe i can do this and and so there's
no suggestion here for if someone should
or shouldn't do that the suggestion here
that that person that thinks they can or
can't that sense of sense of
um a doer isn't really happening but
also the sense of the doer is also being
done too
so even the sense of a doer there's no
choice in the
sense of choice there's no
doer doing the sense of a doer
there's no doer doing this experience of
free will like
and so it's just weird so there's
nothing to
there's nothing to do and there's
nothing to not do honestly and there's
nowhere to go and there's nowhere to not
go
but
that sense of
person it's
it's it's just done spontaneously when
it's done and i don't know it because
when it's done it's obvious it never
started
so in the end it's just like well
there's no beginning it never was
there's only been just life just
ordinary life
i don't know
yep
yep
so
let's wrap by
saying
this and you and you let me know how you
feel about this do you like
if you are to boil it down
if you are to use a
couple symbols
do you like
boundless energy appearing
and uh yeah i don't that's a good one
yeah i don't know
yeah yeah definitely sure why not
cool why not but but there's no way to
boil something down because
the person's always trying to reduce
life into a concept the person's always
trying to take an abstraction just
abstract a meaning so it's just a
suction it's like a vacuum always
sucking in sucking in
meaninglessness sucking it into a
meaning it's always trying to boil it
down and reduce life into a
understanding
so it's just it's just a machine there's
no choice in it to just but that's
awesome dude so it doesn't matter
because that's also perfection too so it
doesn't really matter anyways but yeah
sure why not but boundless energy life
ordinary life too because actually just
simple ordinary life honestly that's
that's i guess that's my favorite one
simple ordinary life because it's not
complicated because i think when the
person hears
boundless energy
starts to day drought
oh there's
some
me that's gonna wait realize i'm not me
and i am back and nobody lighting and so
really just simple ordinary life all
right it's nothing to wait for nothing
to not wait for
yeah the just the just the one thing
just the one thing about about simple
ordinary life is that
it's just that from a place of
separation yeah or from
from a place of me or
it's just that with the the one thing
with uh simple ordinary life is that it
can still be set
from a place of
separation or from meaning and so that
the one there because uh
it can still come from the illusion of
separation from from
an expression of this
there's no illusion anyways because
there's no illusion and there's no
separation there's no there's not even
an illusion because thinking there's an
illusion it's part of the illusion
there's no illusion really to get rid of
there's no illusion to see through
really there's no real illusion but um i
know what you mean like simple ordinary
also simple ordinary life the person can
be deeply dissatisfied because for the
person ordinary life is dissatisfying
and they think satisfaction is in a
future idea
and so
how could you just say ordinary life is
is extraordinary the person's very
deeply decided well depends on the
person sometimes it's a deep
dissatisfaction with ordinary life
sometimes it's just a subtle very subtle
this isn't it my the next job the next
partner the next lifestyle you know so
like an animal like a lion or a dolphin
or an aunt yeah like being dissatisfied
it's a constant agitation it's kind of
like a constant
um
dissatisfaction or agitation yeah
which is what dukkha is suffering is
dissatisfaction yeah like all these they
there's i mean there are many ways to
kind of describe
the same thing i try to use the less
complicated the better because it's
really simple but um
dissatisfaction is really it like that's
a great way to put it so simple ordinary
life without any dissatisfaction
yeah but then dissatisfaction can appear
too so or like you know if my my dog
throws up and i have to clean it up whoa
it's just gross but it's obvious that
there's no alternative to what's
appearing
yeah yeah exactly so it's just what is
appearing as dog throw up and cleaning
that up yeah yeah
without a center without a center which
is why i keep saying boundless energy
because boundless energy is awesome yeah
without a center yeah but before when i
felt like a person and the dog threw up
i would feel oh i should have fed him at
this time of day and i should have i
should i could have done something to
change the outcome like so before if the
dog threw up i felt like the doer maybe
it's my fault maybe you know something's
you know but now it's just throwing up
cleaning it up
making sure he's not sick you know what
i'm saying it's immediately life
seeming to play out but before there was
a sense of i am the doer and i'm
responsible if something goes wrong i'm
responsible if my life goes wrong i'm
responsible if i
am a failure or if i'm a success or i'm
this or that so but now there's no sense
of
life is personal but yeah there's no
center anywhere and yeah balance
i love boundless life and energy and the
thing also like i feel like my
vocabulary is
changing and i don't even know what's
happening so just you know i don't know
but who knows yeah
that's the beauty
is that
that
what you appeared as a couple years ago
um
was
the appearance of not as liberated and
not as awake and not as present
and
same thing here and same thing with so
many others and it's really beautiful
that that this appearance of a
collective awakening seems to be
harmonizing more with nature with each
other with the planet with
maximizing prosperity
and it's at the end of the day it's
quite
simple ordinary life appearing and it's
beautiful and it's it's amazing
yeah
yeah
and also like i feel you know it
couldn't have been any other way so like
the apparent dream of how like it ended
when it apparently ended but you know it
couldn't have ended sooner or later it
just kind of it just it just kind of
it couldn't have been any other way and
it just seems to play out and i don't
know so
and there wasn't an actual real dream
but
i knew you know from that perspective
like all i can really say is
whatever seems to play out it couldn't
be any other way
yeah
i don't know there's no real dream
anyway i feel not genuine like if i eat
like that's also too like kind of i
don't feel genuine when i actually kind
of talk about it as a real thing or a
real person or a real dream like it's
kind of like there's no obviously no
person so it's like weird but i don't
know
i know we're gonna wrap up soon but i'm
free too yeah let's do it let's
let's let's wrap and then
um i would love to
explore
uh potential uh uh like downstream
conversations maybe uh a couple times a
year or whatnot just to catch up and
play together and just see what's uh
appearing and it'll be fun are you yeah
awesome yeah awesome just let me know
and just
we'll see what happens awesome
beautiful yeah and the links are in the
bio below to ariana's youtube channel um
she's got a lot of great content there
go and give her videos a watch subscribe
to the channel like the content
and there's also the links in the bio to
her
zoom meetings she has a non-duality zoom
meetings that she hosts you can find
those down there you can also send her
an email if you're interested
and get in touch
and also if the video of our
conversation brought you value give it a
like help the algorithm
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet drop us a comment below with your
resonance on the episode we'd love to
hear from you
and
also
uh if the video was interesting share it
with other people and let's uh let's
make some more fun little waves of
non-duality across the collective
and that is all fam infinite love thank
you for tuning in
and thanks ariana for appearing on the
show i'll end the stream but then we'll
stay in the studio for a minute okay so
just hold tight
cool
thank you
bye
bye